American Tantrum: The Donald J.
Trump Presidential Archives.
I love colon titles.
Oh, my gosh. So funny.
I love everything to be in 900-
Book. Colon.
I've had a book colon before.
That's rough.
Welcome back to the show, it's
You Up with Nikki Glaser.
Oh, we've added someone
so special to the room today.
We have Anthony Atamanuik
already here
from the documentary
"A President Show Documentary:
The Fall of Donald Trump",
which premiers tonight at 11:00
on Comedy Central.
Also with us Ashley Graham.
Hi. I was about to put
in a cough drop.
I was like, what's she doing?
Should I say it.
Ashley Graham,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for being here.
So happy to be here.
You beautiful bitch.
am so excited to meet you
and see you and see you.
You're just as radiant
and lovely in person
as I knew you would be.
Thank you.
And you have a new podcast out.
You're not only a model,
an author, an advocate,
you're now a podcaster.
Welcome to the club.
Thank you.
I mean, it's kind of
like an intense club.
There's a lot of us.
There's so many podcasts
and everyone goes, "Oh,
I'm not gonna start a podcast.
There's already too many."
I'm glad you started one.
I listen to it.
I listened to your first episode
and I think you are a natural.
It was such a fun show
to listen to.
Thank you.
The podcast is called
"Pretty Big Deal".
It is available on iTunes.
And it came out of the gate
a fully formed great show.
Like you feel like
the first time
you listen to a show
they're finding their bearings
and they're figuring it out.
You're a natural host.
Well, thank you. I have to give
so much credit to my team
because everybody
was like, "Okay.
This is the structure of a show
and then this is what we do
and this is
how you ask questions."
And I was like, "I don't know
what you're saying structure is,
so I'm just gonna go ask
a bunch of questions."
And they were like, "Okay."
And then we just kinda went
in there and was like,
"Well. That's how you not do it.
So this is how you do do it."
And then we put
a little bit of structure in.
Now I know
what structure is.
Gotcha. So you had to mess up.
You did test runs
and stuff like that?
I did one test run
with my best friend,
which was the worst idea
ever because
I know too much about her.
Which I didn't know that
it was gonna be a bad idea.
Who's your best friend?
Rachel.
Rachel [Ashwill inaudible],
she's a real estate agent.
I've known her
since I was 17.
I was her first client
and she was my first client.
Whatever.
And we ended up living together
and now she's just been
my ride or die.
Gotcha.
However, I was like,
"So tell me about that time
in 2010 when you duh duh duh."
And she was like,
"Bitch, if you ask me
that ever again on camera,
I'm gonna kill you."
And I'm like, "Oh.
Can't talk about that one."
So, yeah.
It's better, yes,
will we ever see that episode?
No. We burnt it.
Are you kidding me?
Your first episode is
with Kim Kardashian West.
Yes.
I went into it being like,
"What am I gonna think
about this?
Do I even care?
I feel like I know
everything I need to know."
Everybody thought that.
And you did a fantastic job.
First of all, I got to know
you a lot through it,
which I think is important
as a host,
but you didn't overtake
the conversation.
I felt like I knew both of you
by the end of it
and I really, really love her
in a way that I didn't before.
She was so open and just real
and I definitely got
a few stories
that none of us have heard.
Yes.
I thought that was fantastic.
I was such a fan girl
in the beginning.
I was like, "And then you were
wearing this
with this dress and this hair
and I knew the hair dresser
that did the duh duh duh."
Afterwards I was like,
"Oh, my God.
I'm that idiot
that totally went in."
But, the interview
was so much fun.
We put our feet up,
we had a great time.
Yeah. You really brought out
a side of her
which was that
I had never seen before.
She was super intelligent
and just open
and didn't seem
to be trying to-
Impress anybody
or be anybody else.
Yeah. Or say the right things.
But that's the thing about Kim.
She is a mogul.
She is super intelligent
and she has done so much
to get to where she is.
And if you think about it
from where she started
to who she is today,
that's totally unheard of
for someone like that to have
a career and be where she is.
So I praise her everyday,
not like how I praise God, but-
Praise Jesus every morning
with a Kim verse.
Praise Kim. And then she said...
You and your husband do Kim
Kardashian study.
But I have to say she is
definitely a role model
when it comes to business.
Yeah.
I remember reading about her
that she, really young,
found a way
to resell boots on eBay?
And she made
thousands of dollars
as a high school student.
She's a savvy business woman
and the Kanye West story
that he gave her
a million dollars-
On Mother's Day.
On Mother's Day. So get this-
I don't know this.
What is this story.
You guys didn't listen
to my podcast?
I'm really sorry.
You didn't research.
You will learn a new side of Kim
Kardashian that you didn't know.
I wanna hear this, yeah.
Okay, so she, how did it begin?
Because she wanted to-
Okay, I'll tell the story.
Yes, please, sorry.
So there was a brand that wanted
to pay Kim a million dollars,
but it all looks kind of like
Yeezy.
So Kim asked Kanye,
"Do you think it's okay.
It's a lot of money."
And he was like,
"I'd rather you not."
And she was like,
"You know what.
Because I love you
and because you're my husband,
I'm gonna honor that."
Cut to Mother's Day,
a man walks into the kitchen.
I imagine him wearing a bow tie.
Hands her an envelope and,
I'm like, first of all,
who let this man into your home?
Right?
Isn't that a little creepy?
Anyway, so hands her an envelope
and it's a million dollar
check from Kanye
and then it's also a contract
with Equity within Yeezy.
And so he was like,
"Thank you for always riding
with me and not taking that job.
Here's a million dollars."
Oh, my God. I love that.
So many things about that story
I love is that a million dollars
doesn't seem like a lot
to Kim Kardashian.
But it was.
She was like,
"That's a lot of money."
She was still like, I want
a million dollars. I want this.
And the contract is a...
That's crazy.
The contract, yeah.
Having that discussion with
your husband and being like,
"This is a lot of money.
We have kids.
We have a life.
Can you let me do this?"
And he's just like,
"I'd rather you not."
And she goes, "Okay. Yeah.
Fine." That was like such a-
Loyalty.
Really cute story.
You've been with your husband
for eight years.
Eight years we've been married.
That is insane.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
How long have you been together?
Nine. We only dated a year.
Oh wow.
What?
Yeah.
Wait, why did that
happen so fast?
And how did you know?
There's a few things.
So, we met at church
and then I was like,
"I don't wanna boyfriend."
And he was like, "Well,
I'm gonna be your boyfriend."
And then I fell in love with him
.
Yeah.
And we waited til
we were married to have sex.
So that was something, also,
that sped the process up.
Sure. I like that you admit it.
Of course I'm gonna admit it.
Cuz I wasn't a virgin.
I knew what I was missing.
Right.
Oh, so you weren't a virgin.
No. We weren't virgins. No.
Why did you guys decide that?
You both weren't virgins?
My ex boyfriend was so terrible
and I realized that I was giving
so much of myself up to men
who were not deserving of me.
And as a girl who was just
dating all over New York City
and I would have boyfriend
for three months here,
a boyfriend
for six months there,
and then I got into a really
nasty relationship with a guy.
I was like,
"I'm giving it up too soon.
And I'm not making
these guys work for it.
I'm not valuing who I am."
So the next guy I date,
he's not getting any of this
until at least I see
a ring on my finger.
Then I decided
it's not just a ring.
It's gotta be the wedding day.
So then I met my husband and
sure enough we met in church.
Made it a lot easier because
we had the same believe system.
Yeah.
Right, right.
So I didn't have to convince
someone like, "No.
Trust me.
It's gonna work out."
But it's worked out. We've been
married for eight years.
I love this story because it
is validating
everything that I am doing
with my life right now.
Really? Are you celibate?
Yeah. I pretty much am.
You don't get anything until...
And it's not even
marriage for me,
but it's until
you prove yourself.
You set your own parameters,
but I'm done being this girl.
I think we grow up
as women thinking...
we've been sold this lie
about blue balls
and how if a guy doesn't finish
he's gonna hate us
and he's gonna be mad at us
and we're gonna be bad women.
And it's not men that are
necessarily perpetuating this,
it's just something that has
gotten into our consciousness
as women that they need,
if you engage
in a hook up with a guy,
if he doesn't finish then
there's something wrong-
Then you did
something mean to him.
You did something wrong
and he might not call you,
he might not get you
an Uber home, or whatever it is.
You know what, usually if you
don't finish him off
then he does call you.
Exactly. Cuz you finish them off
over and over and you realize
even when you do finish them
they still do
all those things anyway.
They talk bad about you behind
your back and all the things.
Men are hunters.
They want something to hunt.
And they also want something
to be able to say,
"I got her and I did it
the right way."
That was something
that I learned in dating
at least half of the assholes
in New York City.
Yeah. It's my new thing
and I like to hear
that you actually waited
til marriage
and that this wasn't...
you'd already had sex before.
Yeah.
You knew what you were
missing out on.
A lot of it.
But you knew that having sex-
It's also the person.
You need to keep something.
It's the person too.
It's who the person is.
Yes.
Just sex alone with someone is
not necessarily an intimate act.
It has to be with
the person you care about.
I can't believe
I'm participating in this...
But it's true.
I think that intimacy,
90% of intimacy
is about your eyes,
your touch,
and all the things
that matter around that.
Yep.
Just tickling the pickle is this
sort of neural discharge part
of it that's totally different.
And I mean, a lot of discharge.
Wait. I think I vomited
in my mouth a little bit.
How did that go over?
Was he like, I'm down?
And then you guys got married.
Had he had sex before?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
So you both were just like,
"This is what we're
gonna do together."
Yeah. He was down and,
I don't know, it just worked.
And then so we made a deal
where we wouldn't sleep over
at each other's homes
because we knew if we did then,
hello, morning wood.
Morning [inaudible 00:10:26].
We know how it goes down.
Yes.
So we did these 24 hour dates
where he would pick me up
and it would be in the evening.
We would spend the whole night
out just walking around the city
or going to shows,
25 hour diners.
And then we would spend
the whole day together.
We really got to know each other
and we built this friendship
that you cannot destroy
because our trust,
our communication is so on point
that today we can literally be
so blunt with each other
and then just go right
into lovey dovey mode.
Right. By these 24 hour
dates you mean
that you weren't alone
in a bedroom together.
We would sometimes go over
to each other's homes
and watch movies
or just hang out.
We weren't sleeping
in the same bed.
You weren't setting yourself up.
Yeah, exactly.
You're right.
It will happen if you
put yourself in that position
because you get horned up enough
you start making deals
with yourself.
We were making out.
He's not gonna be weird
after this.
I'm just gonna do it.
And I just can't,
if you do have sex
with someone too soon, girls
who are listening, it's okay.
You can always get
that power back.
But just try to hold out
as long as you can.
It's never a bad idea.
It really is never a bad idea.
I've never seen it backfire
on a girl to hold back.
Never.
To not text first,
to not withhold sex.
It is withholding, but you're
doing it for yourself.
You're not doing it
to punish him.
I don't think it's withholding
when you haven't
already given it.
That's a good point.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a really good point.
It's not yours.
It also shouldn't be
transactional, personally.
Yeah. Yeah.
I think that the whole idea
should be you wanna weed out
the pressuring,
toxic masculinity
and sort of garbage-
Yeah.
-that floats around.
And that's exactly
what happened with me.
I started dating guys
and they were like,
"What. You're waiting? Why?"
And then they would try
to hook up with me,
I'm like,
"No, you don't understand."
And then they wouldn't
call me back.
And you weed through the guys
who just wanna
have sex with you.
Yes. You saying "I'm not
gonna have sex with you"
doesn't always work.
It's not like that guy
is just gonna chase you
to the end of the world.
No.
They'll give up if they're not
really meant to be with you.
Yeah. But that's part of it.
They're not all that thirsty.
I think if there are people
who like to have a lot of sex
and they all like it and all
those people meet each other
and they're fine
without commitment.
I'm saying those folks
should go for it too.
I don't think
there's one right way,
but I think that
the problem is that,
or at least hearing
what you're saying,
is the worst one
is the sort of pressuring,
and the blue balls,
and come on and I can do it.
And the thing that any young man
who's past through their 20s,
especially if you grew up
in the '70s and '80s,
that was the language
you were taught as a man.
Yes.
It's a hard one to undo.
And you have to undo it.
All the men out there, undo it.
I feel like anyone who went
through the D.A.R.E program
was also given this aside
propaganda session of blue balls
and how if you wanna guy
to like you he's gotta finish.
I'm talking to myself here,
by the way.
You are an angel
to me right now.
Aw.
I already look up to you and
to hear you say that that's...
And your relationship has been
eight years strong now,
which is, to be a young girl
married for eight years
is something to celebrate.
Yeah. We got married
when I was 22.
That's crazy. And you can tell,
the way you speak of him,
you can tell how good
your marriage is.
I'm just projecting, but.
That's the other thing.
Marriage is not an easy road.
You've got your peaks
and your valleys
and you just have to remember
are you both committed.
Are you both
gonna stay in this?
I think that the other thing
that people don't talk about
is the highs
and lows in marriage
and especially
when you're younger.
And our fifth year
was our hardest year.
It's because we didn't get
to see each other very much.
We fought and we were like,
what are we doing?
Why are we married?
What's the whole situation?
Wow.
And I think that if you remember
you made a commitment
to each other
and if you both work your asses
off to stay committed,
to stay connected,
to stay communicating,
there's nothing
that can tear you up.
Unless if one of you, you know.
What is the work? Give me
one specific thing that is work?
Cuz you hear that.
When my husband and I
have an argument.
You know that tension
that's still left in the air
where you're like,
"Okay. We're over it but we're
still pissed at each other."
You're like, slamming drawers.
The spirit of the fight.
Yeah.
The fight is disembodied
from you and it just exists.
There's nothing else to discuss.
Right.
But you've both said
you're sorry.
So we have this game
where we play the nice game.
And whoever says,
"Let's play the nice game."
The other person has to say
something nice
about the other one.
So if I say to Justin,
"Let's play the nice game."
He has to say
something nice about me
and then I have to say
something nice about him.
It cannot be physical
because, duh,
we're both attracted
to each other
and it can't be something
that's surface level like,
"I really like how you cleaned
the dishes today."
Right.
Okay.
Right? And if you're the person
who doesn't say the nice thing
then you're the first person
on the face of the Earth
that ever cheated
on the nice game.
So then we shun each other.
It's like, "Oh, okay.
You're the first person ever."
So you're the first one
to lost this game.
Yes. So you have
to say something nice.
And what that does is it creates
this loving connection again
because you have...
it's kind of like
saying affirmations
or saying gratitude to your day
in telling this person,
"Thank you for supporting me
through this decision."
Or "Thank you so much for
taking the time to care for me."
Whatever it is.
And it's like, okay.
We're back to square one
and everything's fine.
Yeah. The nice game.
I love that.
I like it a lot.
You have to be so selfless
when you're married.
Because everything is about
that person and vice versa.
Every guard has to go down.
And that is something that is
very, very hard for people.
Yes.
And hard to maintain and do
and a lot of times
you fail at it, but you try.
Of course.
And I think the other one
is there are things
about your partner
that you just never will like.
Yeah. The 80/20 rule.
When you're dating.
Yeah, exactly.
Have you ever heard
of the 80/20 rule?
I haven't, but I can guess.
But, tell me.
If you're dating someone it has
to be 80%
of what this person gives that
you're obsessed with,
the other 20% is kind of like,
okay, whatever,
I'll just deal with it.
Right.
But if it's like 70% is great
and 30% is like,
oh, hell no,
then you have to walk away
because that 30%
will get under your skin.
Oh, man.
But you can take 20.
It'll destroy it eventually.
No one's perfect.
It's hard to math
that out though.
Are you making a chart?
You figure it out.
It's experiencing when you go,
"Oh."
The relief of going,
"I don't have to fix this.
I'm not here to change it.
This is just a part of them
and I just gotta accept it
and stop being crazy about it."
And our thing we do,
"Can I make a confession?"
And a confession is when you say
something you're feeling
and your partner does not
comment, respond, or anything.
You just say it
and then you go, "I'm done."
And the thing
is being listened to
is the number one thing
that gets lost in the shuffle.
Yeah.
Is truly being listened to.
And you wanna fix, cuz you love,
and you wanna try to do...
And so it's a really
good way of going,
"I gotta make a confession.
I'm really anxious
about going to this party
and doing this thing."
And then you just let it go cuz
sometimes you just wanna say it.
It's not about it being fixed.
You just wanna say it.
And not be judged, yeah.
You wanna be heard.
I think when I look back
on my relationships
and I'm kind of
getting back together
with someone I've been off
and on for six years-
Why?
Because I'm realizing
the 80/20 thing.
And I'm realizing I always
broke up because of the 20
and that the 80 really,
I've dated other people,
and I joke about it,
but when I date other people
I look at my ex and I go,
"Oh, my God.
He's the best I can do."
Because I feel like I did
really well five years ago
and I've dated since then
and you just compare
and you go, "No.
That was pretty great.
What am I doing?"
And he's grown over time
and I've grown over time.
But something
that I really didn't realize,
and I think would help
in a marriage
or a long term relationship,
is, honestly,
just empathy and being like,
"They're a different person
than I am.
And they're interpreting
everything
from a different perspective."
I don't know why I never even
grasped that until this year.
But, literally, I just,
every time
we would get in a fight
I only saw things
from I would never
treat him that way,
so he must not love me.
That has to do
with your love language.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm doing
this love counseling.
See, I told you. You're good.
Yeah.
Have you guys ever read
The Five Love Languages?
I know of it.
No.
Okay. We read it on our
honeymoon because we're dorks.
Whoa.
And my love language is acts
of service
and his is physical touch
and time spent.
I could never touch you, like,
maybe we'll have sex
and it'll be great
but I don't wanna be touched
when I walk in the door
and I don't need
to speak to you.
He needs both of those things.
Oh, yeah.
Men usually do.
I'm like, "Touch me.
Touch me for God's sake."
And they wanna spend time.
And I'm like, okay, if you got
everything on the To
Do list done,
if you booked that vacation,
if you did duh duh duh for me,
then oh, my God.
I'll do anything
you want me to.
Whoa.
Interesting.
So, this love language
is you love the way
that you wanna be loved.
And he's loving you the way
he wants to be loved.
So you have to understand
each other's love language
in order to love that person.
Why would you want me
to touch you all the time?
That's ridiculous.
Cuz you don't wanna be touched.
How annoying. Right?
And he's like, "No, no.
Please rub my head. I love it."
And I'm like,
"Oh, here we go again."
But now when I rub his head
then he does all the things
I want him to do.
The love language book is legit.
People have such a... even me.
I'm working on having empathy
and I realize it's something
that you put yourself
in someone else's shoes,
but I only have my shoes.
And it's so hard
to imagine other shoes.
But, that is one way to do it
is to just read
that book your honeymoon.
It's gotta have helped.
It did. It really did.
And the human psyche
is a congress.
In a way you can understand
or empathize in the sense
that there's a part of you
that is more representative
of that other person.
It's just the captain
that drives the ship,
the part of you that's you
is the primary part,
but there's all these
other shades and parts
so when you're interacting
with your partner
you're also playing out
all of your family systems.
Yes.
All of the different
relationships
you've had throughout your life.
It's a complex mess
that sometimes works out
and if it's really good you
get dinner.